Today at Google.
We are delighted to welcome Lathop Paul Nippon and Deepa Prahalad.
Um,
Dr uh,
Paulownia pawn is a professor of medicine at Stanford where for the last 20
years,
shits has studied and worked on cardiovascular disease and diabetes and South
Asians.
Uh,
Miss Lod comes from a management consulting background specializing in emerging
markets and is now on the board of a rocky world where she focuses on growth and
design.
And she wrote a book titled Predictable Men,
it predictable magic,
which attempts to unite strategy and design thinking.
They are here today to discuss today to discuss their work at a rodeo world,
a global health nonprofit organization,
working to prevent noncommunicable diseases,
eg diabetes,
heart disease,
cancer and chronic lung diseases through health education and lifestyle change.
Please join me in welcoming to Google Lofa Pony,
pawn and deeper Prahalad.
Okay.
Thank you for coming out today.
I'm going to tell you a little bit about myself.
My name's Lotta Pony up and I'm currently a professor of medicine at Stanford.
I spend most of my time doing research and heart disease and diabetes.
I do work on electronic health records,
mortality records,
and I do clinical trials in type two diabetes,
trying to promote physical activity in people with type two diabetes.
Um,
and I teach first year medical student population health.
So that's how to take care of large groups of people.
And I also see patients in Stanford's,
um,
executive medicine program and we're trying to start a genetic and
pharmacogenetic testing program there to bring evidence based,
uh,
genetic testing.
Um,
so I want to,
before we start today,
um,
have us think a little bit about diabetes and um,
and I'm going to be presenting some statistics on diabetes around the world,
but,
um,
if you could think for a moment why,
why you think diabetes is increasing so much and prevalence.
Um,
now you probably have heard in the papers that diabetes is increasing and I
wonder if anyone in the audience has any thoughts on that.
Maybe what brought you here today?
If you have a family member
with diabetes,
American Diet,
Standard American diet,
any more color to that?
What is the standard American Diet?
Yeah.
Too much sugar and fat.
And in fact,
one of my colleagues at Stanford recently wrote a paper that was published in
Jama showing that both low fat and low carb diets when healthy promoted weight
loss.
So that kind of put an end to the low carb,
low fat debate.
I hope.
I think we will continue to debate about that because people feel that certain
diets work for them more than,
uh,
more than another.
But,
um,
it did show in the end that a calorie is a calorie and having the appropriate
amount of calories for your body size is,
um,
helpful for,
maintaining a healthy weight and preventing chronic diseases in general.
Okay.
So let's talk about,
uh,
the global epidemic of diabetes.
And particularly,
you know,
what we're trying to do in preventing this epidemic.
So this is a graph of a diabetes cases in the u s so you can see the u s and
around the world and in the u s so you can see in the u s in Green,
they're 37 million cases of diabetes.
And the black part on the side shows you what percentage is undiagnosed.
So you can see in different areas of the world,
there are different proportions of undiagnosed diabetes.
Um,
and um,
and I hope that you and the audience have gotten tested for diabetes,
but can anyone tell me how we test for diabetes,
insulin and blood sugar?
Great answers.
So that's the absolute correct answer.
So we try to check your blood sugar.
So we check,
um,
either a fasting number in the morning of your blood,
uh,
blood sugar or what we call a glycosylated hemoglobin,
hemoglobin a one c because as we have more glucose in our bodies,
it attaches onto our hemoglobin and we can measure those levels.
And then another way that we can do it is through an oral glucose tolerance
test.
So,
um,
and that's sort of drinking a,
a glucose load and then checking your glucose after two hours to see how your
body processes glucose.
So all of these things you can imagine are a little hard to do because they
involve blood tests in resource limited settings.
So I hope in partnership with technology companies like Google that we'll be
able to improve the diagnosis of diabetes and um,
be able to do it without expensive blood tests going forward.
So,
so you can see in the world,
382 million people are living with diabetes and about half of those are
diagnosed under diagnosed and half are undiagnosed.
Okay.
So the top 10 countries by number of diabetes cases.
So the top countries are China and India.
The prevalence of diabetes is about the same,
so about 10%.
It ranges in these countries from 7% to 14% depending on if you're urban or
rural.
And,
um,
what your familial risk factors are.
And the reason that the number of cases are so high in China and India is
because the absolute number of people are so high,
right?
In China,
India,
they're our largest countries in the world.
And then,
so you can see the u s is um,
is third there and a,
a distant third.
And,
um,
the number of cases of diabetes in the u s are increasing as well.
And the greatest projected increase our is in the western Pacific.
So China,
Korea,
Japan,
Vietnam,
Indonesia,
and Australia,
the number of cases are projected to increase by about 50%.
Okay.
And this is just a,
um,
a,
a graph showing the economic,
um,
background of these countries.
So high income is yellow,
upper middle is orange,
lower middle is pink,
and low income is red.
And so you can see there again that the proportion of undiagnosed changes
depending on the economic background and situation of those countries,
um,
with a really high proportion undiagnosed,
again in India and China and the high income countries having,
um,
a little bit less undiagnosed,
but still a significant proportion even in the u s we have a significant
proportion of undiagnosed diabetes,
um,
simply because people aren't going in and getting tested.
And it does take some effort to go ahead and get tested for type two diabetes.
And Asia represents about 60% of the diabetic populations worldwide.
Okay.
So,
um,
we are focusing today particularly on South Asia and this is um,
doctor Prahalad who will speak after me is the,
um,
the purpose of the nonprofit reducing diabetes in um,
South Asia,
which has a particularly high prevalence of diabetes.
So this is a map of South Asia.
We commonly think of India,
um,
representing South Asia and it is a major part of the subcontinent and 90% of
the South Asians in California are from India,
but also South Asians are from Pakistan and Nepal,
Butan and Bangladesh and Sri Lanka as well.
And this is a map from the bay of the bay area of the census in this area.
And what percent of people are Asian,
Indian by county?
So,
um,
so you can see there,
particularly around Alameda and the Fremont area particularly,
it's about 10% Asian Indians.
A one out of 10 people are South Asian.
And in Santa Clara where we are are now about one out of 15 people are Asian
Indian.
So this is a study I did earlier in my career and looking at mortality records
of California and looking at coronary heart disease,
um,
because diabetes is a risk factor for heart disease and diabetes is so much
higher in South Asians,
um,
particularly among young Indian men.
So 25 to 44,
their risk of heart disease is almost three times as high.
So you that tall red bar compared to the total population which is in green,
the non Hispanic white population in orange,
the Hispanic population and blue,
um,
the African American or black population and Brown and then Chinese population
of blue and a Japanese population in yellow there.
And the Indian population is in red.
And,
um,
what got me into the business that I'm in is that my father died of a heart
attack at 39.
I grew up in Michigan and lived there at the time,
but he represented that three times higher risk in the young men,
25 to 44.
So I encourage you if,
if you know of anyone,
um,
in this,
uh,
race,
ethnic group,
um,
there are particularly high risk for heart disease.
And should be tested for diabetes and other risk factors for heart disease.
So,
um,
this is another study that I did using data from Palo Alto Medical Foundation.
So we collected race,
ethnic information at Palo Alto medical foundation because it is so highly
prevalently Asian.
So the bay area's about 30% Asian and it has good representation of all of these
Asian subgroups.
Um,
and you want to hear,
get their care from Palo Alto Medical Foundation particularly?
No,
it's a great place.
It's a,
it's a good place to get care.
Um,
so,
um,
so you can see that all Asians in general have higher odds.
So this is the likelihood of having diabetes among that group compared to non
Hispanic whites about double the risk.
So men are on the left,
women are on the right in all the arrows and the statistically significant,
um,
numbers are in bold there.
So you can see that among the Asian subgroups when you aggregate them,
there is a higher risk of diabetes.
And when you desegregate the Asian subgroups,
some groups have much higher risk than other groups,
namely Asian Indians and Filipinos in this case have three to four times the
risk.
And other Asian groups also have higher risk like Chinese,
Japanese and Korean.
And these are all age adjusted as well.
Um,
given the,
the,
um,
slightly younger age substructure of Asians in the u s okay.
So why,
why do Asians and perhaps uh,
um,
Asian Indians in particular have more risk of diabetes?
So this is a paper that was published in Lancet,
um,
by two of the people that I consider my mentors,
yogic and Yedgan and they're an Indian weddings.
You can see the Saris and the background and um,
yet nick is the Non Hispanic White reach researcher on your left.
And yogic is the Indian researcher on your right.
And you can see that they have an identical BMI body mass index of 22.3,
but their body fat,
and sorry,
it's covered there by um,
the notation,
the slide advancer but it's three times as high for the Indian researcher.
It's about 9% versus 27%.
So at an identical level of body mass index,
there's more fat.
And so next to them they have dexa scan.
So these are um,
scans that we normally do for bone,
but you can also see fat and muscle in those scans.
And in a Dexa scan muscle is more white.
So you can see the non Hispanic white researcher has more muscle.
You can see it particularly around the thighs in the abdominal area,
whereas the Indian researcher does is more sort of dark on that Dexa scan.
So that's indicative of more fat.
So Asians,
um,
based on data like this and other work that I'll show you,
the WHO recommended a lower body mass index cut point for Asians.
So it's 23 and lower.
And for non Hispanics,
whites it's 25 and lower.
And um,
so this is a study that I did showing that at similar levels of body mass index,
there's higher risk of something called Metabolic Syndrome,
which is pre diabetes.
It's combination of triglycerides,
low HDL,
which is the good cholesterol,
High Glucose,
um,
obesity as well as blood pressure,
greater than one 30,
over 85.
So you can see on the x axis,
on the horizontal axis is the body mass indices.
And on the y axis is the probability of having metabolic syndrome.
And Asian Indians are on the red curve and Nice Fanuc whites or are on the blue
curve.
And you can see that at every level of body mass index,
the Asian Indians have higher probability of having this prediabetes.
So,
and it is very difficult to have a BMI of 23 at this moment I stand in front of
you with a Bmi of 23,
but sometimes on Mondays after a weekend of lots of parties,
my,
I gained three pounds and I'm a very short person and my Bmi is 24.
So it's very hard to maintain that BMI of 23 but I have to do it because I have
to practice what I preach.
So,
so you can see here,
and this is also from Palo Alto Medical Foundation,
um,
the,
the range of um,
body mass index for non Hispanic whites on the left and Asian Indians on the
right for women on the left and men on the right.
And you can see that,
um,
a BMI of 25 and higher,
so 50% of women in the Palo Alto Medical Foundation,
electronic health record database.
So there's about a million people in that database.
50% of non Hispanic women were an at risk BMI and about 60% of Asian Indian
women had a BMI of 23 and higher.
So we have a long way to go to get people at the appropriate level of weight.
And um,
for men it was eight out of 10 non Hispanic white men were not at the
appropriate or optimal weight and nine out of 10 Asian Indian men.
So when I was at Palo Alto Medical Foundation had a specific clinic for South
Asians and um,
nine out of 10 of the people that I saw,
you know,
we had to do work to get them down to a lower level of body weight.
So when you go to see your doctor,
your doctor might use your clinical data,
including your gender and your HDL or good cholesterol and your total
cholesterol,
and whether your blood pressure is high or low or whether or not you smoke to
estimate your risk of atherosclerotic cardiovascular disease.
This is called an Asmr CVD risk calculator.
So one thing that I want us to be aware of is that these risk calculators are
mainly based on non Hispanic,
white European populations and they mate might underestimate the risk in some
groups such as South Asians.
I also do work in desegregating Hispanic subgroups.
So Puerto Ricans and Cubans can also be underestimated.
So,
so you should be aware that um,
our,
our current risk calculators may not be accurate in all groups and we should be
aware of what data was used to create those risks.
Predictions.
And I hope that with um,
aggregating larger and larger data sets that we'll be able to,
um,
improve our risk prediction.
Okay.
So what can we do?
And,
um,
doctor [inaudible] who will speak after me will speak a little bit more about
the nonprofit and what they are doing specifically.
But,
um,
you know,
we heard that it's sort of the western lifestyle and,
um,
you sort of hit it right on the head with a red meat sugars sitting at a
computer.
I'm smoking,
um,
refined grains,
traffic,
alcohol,
you know,
sort of all of these things that are,
um,
uh,
contributing to the diabetes epidemic.
Um,
but what,
you know,
one thing that I want to sort of point out in a point that I make is that in
rural areas that have agrarian lifestyles,
diabetes rates are actually quite low,
right?
But substance subsistence farming isn't a great way to live for a lot of
reasons,
but diabetes is not very high.
So people tend to have a lot of physical activity,
not a lot of calories,
not a lot of,
uh,
transfats or saturated fats and diabetes rates are low.
But then when they go to more of an urban lifestyle with eating big MACs and
fries.
So high,
high fat diets,
as you mentioned,
these rates of diabetes and cardiovascular disease can go up.
But then we get to live maybe in an area like we do in the bay area where we
have access to exercise like soul cycle and orange theory and um,
Palatino and also access to great food like sprouts.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I think there must be 10 different salad places here.
And so when we improve our socioeconomic status in this country,
we can also lower diabetes rates.
So in the U s people with higher socioeconomic status have lower diabetes rates
and this is changing and developing countries.
But in general,
people with lower socioeconomic status and developing countries had lower rates
of diabetes.
And this is called the epidemiologic transition.
When you go to higher socioeconomic status and you have in developing countries
and have higher rates of chronic disease.
But we're seeing that flip it a little bit now as well.
But how can we avoid this lifestyle transition?
How can we in developing countries,
you know,
go from this agrarian lifestyle to one in which,
um,
we can translate to more higher ses in higher income countries,
lifestyles.
So I think there's many ways to do this.
And,
um,
and doctor brought a lot,
we'll talk a little bit more about these,
but there's,
and this is from a paper I wrote for the American Heart Association,
um,
looking at the,
uh,
it was called the community guide about how communities can improve rates of
diabetes.
So there's many axes on,
um,
legal community as well as risk factors in early diagnoses.
So one of the things that we did for diet was banned trans fats.
So many countries have banned trans fats and that has helped a,
has been bent the curve in terms of lowering diabetes rates,
also the sedentary lifestyle.
And I think Google has been wonderful in,
um,
you know,
providing all the wonderful bikes outside and,
and other,
um,
healthy,
encouraging healthy habits.
I saw lots of fruit available outside,
um,
and uh,
trying to decrease even sitting at a computer.
So getting up and taking breaks.
I ask my patients to do that a lot.
I will go a long way towards preventing diabetes and other chronic disease,
tobacco.
So we don't have tobacco advertising on in our,
on our TV stations for our kids to see in the u s but this is something that
could be implemented in developing countries and unfortunately developing
countries are the place of the tobacco countries or companies are going to
advertise more and get more smokers.
So that's something that hopefully we can prevent going forward and um,
you know,
treatment of high blood pressure and lipids.
So guidelines on how to screen for this.
I talked a little bit about that as well as um,
early recognition of symptomatic disease,
um,
perhaps with screening with a coronary artery calcium and other newer biomarkers
that are coming out.
So I think we've come a long way in the u s I think that we have learned lessons
here that would be great to transmit to other developing countries.
And I'm looking forward to hearing more about how we can do that.
Yeah,
thank you.
It's an honor to be here.
And I have,
I'm just going to prison.
Uh,
how did they,
what
s
okay.
There we go.
Thank you everybody for coming.
And I would like to just spend a little bit of time.
I think Dr Lotta plenty.
Putin has done a fantastic job of talking about some of the unique challenges
from a medical standpoint and as a nonprofit we really had this additional
challenge of saying we have this information,
but how do we make it actionable and how do we create awareness?
Because I think we all know in emerging markets the awareness is an issue.
The education levels and a lot of people who are in rural areas,
um,
you know,
culturally they're even terms that said,
diabetes is a rich person's disease.
So the awareness that this could happen,
um,
at all is not there in many cases.
And we also,
um,
really said when we looked around at our community here,
there really isn't a single family that hasn't been touched by one of these
diseases in some manner.
And so that's how I got involved.
I don't have a clinical background,
but we really are trying to use design and innovation to help drive awareness
and,
um,
some kind of actionable steps in this process.
MMM.
So what we really did is we have a nonprofit called Arogya world.
Uh,
Rokia is a Sanskrit word that means health to live a life without disease.
And we really said,
um,
you know,
let's see how we can do some kind of actionable chorus to change the course of
chronic disease.
And we really settled on three fundamental pillars of awareness,
action,
really providing people tools,
not just information and creating alliances with people who had information that
we could bring to a new audience.
Um,
currently we've reached about three and 3.7 million people and we have plans to
double our outreach by 2020.
And,
um,
I think,
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on this because I think it was especially a
well covered,
you know,
66% of the deaths in the world,
um,
are from noncommunicable diseases.
And these are 80% of the deaths in developing countries.
And the economic impact of that is absolutely devastating.
And this is really kind of the challenge in emerging markets as you have a lot
of what I would call this good bad news where a lot of this is because of
increased life expectancy from dealing fairly well with infectious disease.
So now people are living long enough,
but because of the demographics you have this challenge where you're dealing
with malnutrition and diabetes and heart disease at the same time,
uh,
which makes it extremely difficult to get information across.
And we know ultimately that three behavior changes can really change the course
of chronic disease,
healthy eating,
exercise and avoiding a diabetes.
And the gains from that are quite significant.
We can actually prevent 80% of diabetes and heart disease and 40% of cancers
that is provided,
the information is available and acted upon.
Um,
and so that's what we have tried to address.
And I think where we realized how important this is is because despite all the
economic growth that people are excited about,
this can actually cripple any economic gains made in many emerging countries.
We have,
you know,
50% of the population that dies from chronic disease,
20% of the population has at least one of these heart disease,
diabetes or some type of cancer.
And Indians also get this,
these diseases much earlier,
um,
in their prime working life.
So you can see the statistics of four point 8 trillion in lost economic output
by 2030 is significant.
And if people don't have that themselves,
there tend to be very concerned because they tend to be caregivers for their
parents.
Uh,
young professionals of both genders,
um,
tend to take on that responsibility.
So it's an issue even for people who are not suffering from one of these.
And what we realized when we did,
I think the first,
um,
10,000 women survey is that this economic impact is particularly severe for
women.
Women have been the focus of a lot of development efforts.
And what we did was take 10 countries around the world and we surveyed a
thousand women and said,
what is the impact in your lives?
And what we're finding is that I'm,
you know,
50% of people,
women are saying,
yes,
we are having to be the primary care giver for even one person with an NCD that
can cut family income by half.
And it also means that about 25% of people who were in our survey were saying
that they have been forced to leave the workforce for extended periods.
So we decided to say,
all right,
how do we empower women?
And that was a fine line because I think many efforts today in wellness,
um,
while they're focus is women they end tend to overwhelm and place a lot of extra
burden solely on one person who may be overburdened.
Um,
in any case,
and we said we need to design something that's flexible,
lean and can be adapted.
Because India is a very rapidly changing environment.
The types of phones that people have where they could receive messages,
where they can understand what their risk factors are changing.
And many of the rural areas,
what has happened is that they are very exciting targets for multinational
companies.
What can be offered cheaply,
however,
is not the sprout stuff.
It's the junk food that stays in a,
it has a very long shelf life and it doesn't wear out easily.
And what's happening is that those are the first things that are offered cause
kind of an entry point to a new group of consumers.
And there isn't a lot of awareness.
People tend to like those because they're in small sample sizes and um,
because they're seen as very hygienic.
So it's a huge problem.
And this is the first generation in many cases in some of those areas that can
afford to give these kids,
um,
treats that they never had.
So we knew we had to really have a low cost scalable and user friendly,
um,
way to do this.
And what we settled on is what I call our doorstep health model,
where we basically say the best way to help women and families is to make sure
that they are not the sole person.
Uh,
they are trying to take charge of their family's health.
We know that beer,
the drivers,
but we have a school program where children in seventh and eighth grade get a
set of really interesting game based exercises where they have the awareness
created and an early stage.
We have a workplace initiative.
Many employers are really interested in making sure that their employees get
this information early on.
And for many people who are out in very disparate areas,
we have a m health messages that come over and they are very simple action based
messages.
We don't give anybody statistics about diabetes.
We tell them concrete things they can do,
you know,
reduce,
um,
the,
your intake of these grains have.
So we've created a very friendly voice that is geared toward inspiring people to
take action
and quickly.
Um,
we have actually a list of our,
um,
genesis we've created.
Um,
our newest thing is an initiative called [inaudible],
which is basically similar to the u s government's my plate where we've taken
nutritional guidelines and tried to create an icon based system so people
actually understand visually what these guidelines mean.
And what we have found,
um,
in terms of our focus is really seeing that we want to use technology to spread
awareness,
but we're not going to become a technology company.
That's not our focus.
We're not trying to create tons of,
of cool,
um,
you know,
add ons to our text messages or even our app in the workplace.
What we're really trying to do in the workplace,
we will have an APP that allows people to measure and record.
But for the text message program,
what we've really done is give people very simple messages and we've tried to
motivate them.
We didn't want to have the voice of a clinician.
We all love and respect our doctors and we get the most expensive ones that we
can afford,
but we don't want to talk to them every day.
Nor do we want to be gentle,
you know,
have gentle reminders from friends and family about what we should eat when
we're overeating.
And so,
um,
having that encouragement was really important.
What we also realized after we had text messages going out for many months in
different languages is of course like anything else,
it becomes easier to tune out.
So we partnered with a company called was the,
that does periodic voice messages as well,
where you actually get a phone call,
every boy,
you know,
a math message of encouragement,
you get a story from somebody else to say,
oh,
this is what I tried,
here's a recipe here was my success story.
And so we are really designed to inspire action and we have this self
reinforcing model of workplace school and um,
text messages so that we make sure that we,
um,
have the same thing coming in from various places.
And what we were very encouraged to find in our very first survey when we
reached a million customers is that for an m health initiative,
we actually were able to achieve a 15% impact based on our surveys.
Just highly unusual.
Nokia was our initial partner in sending out,
um,
these messages and people reported 15% of people reported for behavior changes
in the workplace context over time.
What we would like to do is really do some kind of clinical measurement for
people who opt in.
And we had very good response from the younger generation,
which was the most encouraging.
Um,
we had a lot of students reporting that they had no idea about diabetes.
He had kind of heard a little bit about junk food.
Um,
but a lot of teachers said that these simple activities really brought the
message home.
So in seventh grade,
what we do is we have children take part in activities,
but in eighth grade they do a two year curriculum with us.
In eighth grade they bring their parents and families and to also receive this
information and get concrete tips and people said that was incredibly helpful.
We've partnered with some of the leading NGOs in India,
like a Gasteia and we basically give them training materials and expand our
reach that way.
One of the really exciting things we're doing is this a initiative called
[inaudible],
which we are doing for both north and south Indian food.
The nutrition guidelines in India are very complicated,
even for highly educated people to understand when they say,
you know,
we need 250 grams of a rice or we need this,
what does that actually mean?
So we've created an icon based,
a pictorial model.
We are also working to overtime physically create a plate and serving spoons of
appropriate sizes so people are able to quickly and easily comply.
Um,
so a lot of our focuses exactly on that is really re creating a of ease of
compliance.
Um,
and then our school program,
we also were able to achieve a 14% impact.
And what we really had was simple things relating this battle to snakes and
ladders.
You know,
this is just such a fundamentally different issue for India because the entire
health system has been really geared toward infectious disease where you do need
to have these limited interventions where you have to convince someone to take a
vaccine or something.
But lifestyle diseases are different in the system is not set up for that.
So we found that these very easy visual ways of communicating and giving people
the idea of what the impact of obesity can be,
where a backpack and and try to do a race,
um,
with all these extra pounds on you.
Those are the kinds of things that make it real and tend to have a really
experiential component that stays.
And we have also signed up a lot of leading Indian corporates,
you know,
and organizations like the Indian railways,
which is the largest employer in the world and with 1.3 million employees,
reliance,
Wipro,
um,
many of these companies to say here,
here is a simple downloadable app,
the get the text messages and now we have worked with them and we have partnered
with activity tracking companies and created an APP so that we can be a one stop
shop not only for diabetes but for overall wellness.
And we are testing and measuring the impact of that going forward.
And we're covering about 2.3 million employees currently and we're expecting
that to increase.
And what we knew also is that anything that we designed,
we know that both the tools,
the information,
the guidelines around all of these diseases are evolving very rapidly.
So we didn't want to be too rigid in our design.
We just saw this exciting news about,
you know,
Google having an AI.
Um,
I scan if it can detect your cardiac risk.
We know that we've been able to limit the pinpricks with,
um,
some of the diabetes measuring devices.
Even our understanding of what healthy eating is continues to evolve.
So we realized that kind of positioning ourselves as experts wasn't the way to
gain longterm credibility.
What we wanted to be was somebody who was a friend and partner along the
journey,
um,
and able to create,
a conversation to have information exchange.
We also want to always be able to learn from the people we're trying to serve.
So,
for example,
in our schools program,
what we learned is we gave people information about a healthy breakfast and we
realize,
you know,
there's a component of,
10 to 15% of people who maybe don't get a breakfast before they come to school
and their primary meal during the day is actually,
um,
at their school.
So we said,
how do we then revise and rethink and help families understand what can still
do?
And we realized that this two way information flow is going to be critical for
us going forward.
And that's how we have structured all of our programs have continuously getting
feedback as well as giving suggestions.
We are very excited.
We've been able to reach this kind of impact only because we've had amazingly
committed,
um,
uh,
partners who have helped us really expand in schools,
workplaces.
This is a very small number,
um,
of them.
And what we got as we learned a lot is people saying,
we need this information in the u s what you've learned and the cost at which
you're able to deliver impact really could make a difference in the US and
Europe.
In other emerging markets.
And we agree.
Uh,
so what we are trying to do is actually take what we've learned and expand our
reach here.
We're experimenting with an Indel American Center here in Chicago and trying to
see how we can best adjust some of our programs to audiences in different parts
of the world because there's,
you know,
different access in a different awareness.
We started at California working group last year and as far as going forward,
um,
how would we like to expand our reach is really getting feedback,
having people get involved,
never wants to turn down a donation where@aguildworld.org.
Um,
but what we really want to do is have people share information with us and how
they were able to create those lifestyle changes for themselves,
for their family.
Because we really believe now we have a channel to distribute that information
far and wide,
um,
and help us really spread the word and have an impact.
And I think the cost at which we were able to reach people is,
you know,
pretty amazing given other alternatives,
were able to create outreach for 50 cents.
Um,
we can actually create impact and behavior change m based on our surveys for
about $6 and 50 cents,
which is highly unusual in this type of an effort.
So we're really proud of what we've done so far and happy to take any questions,
um,
and uh,
get your feedback as well.
Thank you.
I have a question.
Okay.
So you,
you showed the picture of the Google,
uh,
scan,
I think it was an eye.
Um,
and I guess that's one example of,
of something Google's doing,
um,
in this,
on this front.
Um,
is there anything else,
um,
that you admire that Google is doing or that you would like to perhaps partner
with Google on or,
or,
um,
some technologies that Google is working on that you think might be able to
help,
uh,
Rokia on its mission?
Well,
I think one thing if you want,
one thing that we have seen some interest from in our workplace,
um,
offerings is really saying,
you know,
young employees in India for example,
even if they are not personally affected,
the burden of caring for parents is something that really looms large for a lot
of people at a very young age.
Um,
and kind of the social contract culturally is that children really take care of
their parents in their old age and because they get that's disease so much
younger,
really helping young employees understand how to care for their parents is one
thing we've seen even in the u s now because so many people where activity
trackers,
they're able to integrate some of that information.
And the city planning India is at a stage where now you're seeing,
okay there to prevent this migration from rural areas to urban areas and all the
consequences that entails.
Um,
people are able to use that data from activity trackers to do smarter planning.
They're probably four to 500 cities in India that are saying we need to create
infrastructure so people stay where they are.
So understanding how does that work,
what does that mean?
Um,
that's one of those really interesting things.
And I know the tech companies and the Pharma had been really involved in trying
to create new diagnostics and new ways to monitor.
So anything that lets people do that at a lower cost,
we'll make this disproportionate impact,
I think in countries like India.
Okay.
So I agree.
And to build on that,
you know,
for my patients,
I would love,
you know,
some type of noninvasive glucose monitoring because I think it is really hard
currently have to prick your finger and put it on a little piece of paper and
stick it in the machine and,
and see what the number is.
And,
um,
so,
so some way,
um,
and I've,
and worked with some companies that are using light technology,
um,
to perhaps look at the wave lengths on hemoglobin to see what the glycosylation
of the hemoglobin is to,
um,
you know,
detect the glucose levels.
So noninvasive glucose monitoring as well as continuous glucose monitoring.
So what,
um,
my,
my patients are so surprised by,
you know,
when they eat,
if they prick their finger,
their glucose is higher and sort of really connecting,
you know,
what you're putting in your body and what's happening to your glucose and what
is happening longterm to your heart disease risk is,
I think,
you know,
would be great to connect the dots for our patients.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
the,
his,
uh,
data that you showed at the beginning,
it's mostly very broad.
Um,
and um,
it's,
it's really like,
I guess it's,
uh,
quite ipidot yellow Chico.
Sorry,
what?
Yes.
Epidemiological.
Yeah.
But I feel like there's actually more detailed available,
for instance,
a plant based diets if you look at the Adventist studies and so on.
Yes.
Um,
so I feel like it could be a little bit more aggressive maybe about,
uh,
promoting very particular things,
um,
to,
to say,
well,
you know,
you say you see you've cut out the cheese,
maybe it not so big a problem in India,
but like I'm,
I'm from Germany,
so I was eating a lot of cheese.
So basically,
you know,
cut off the cheese.
How about the other thing,
you know,
basically you go from avoiding a meet and you avoid first,
but,
but you also look at all the opportunities that it actually increases your
quality of life because,
uh,
it's not just about losing the weight.
I think that basically the,
the,
uh,
the thing is a little bit,
the gist of,
I think what you have in your health information is supposed to be like a,
you low lowering your weight so you reduce your risk of diabetes.
But there's a whole host of other side effects which I positive basically by a
particular diet changes and also of course exercise that comes with it.
Absolutely.
I completely agree with you.
And to restate a little bit is sort of like,
there was some broad strokes about diabetes rates and sort of an ecological,
uh,
sort of a argument that increased die of diabetes is caused by increased obesity
in general.
And so with,
with,
when I talk to patients,
I talk about sort of,
um,
you know,
kind of rough tuning and fine tuning.
So one third of the people in this country or at normal weight,
one third,
one third are overweight and one third is obese.
So in that one third,
that is normal weight.
I agree that fine tuning is very needed.
So you know,
looking exactly at a 24 hour food recalls.
So that's what we do with our patients,
like seeing what they ate in the last 24 hours and seeing where there can be
more protein and a substitution for more of a whole grain than a refined grain.
And some of these interventions that are culturally specific,
like the my Thawley,
right,
I did a study where we interviewed,
um,
South Asian patients and they would go see a nutritionist and,
and the patient said,
oh,
they told me not to eat burgers and fries and cheese and they never ate those
things anyway,
right.
So nobody ever told them about typography and doll and the doll is mostly a
carbohydrate and if you want protein,
you know,
might have to look at other sources.
And,
um,
and that's been a,
you know,
I do studies on physical activity actually in,
in those normal weight diabetics.
Like is it better for them to do strength training or a robotic training?
So we have a study where we're randomizing people to strength training only
aerobic training only or a combination of both.
So I agree there's,
there's plenty of room for fine tuning both diet and exercise that should be
done on an individual level.
Um,
so I agree with you.
and I think from the nonprofit side,
we were just concerned that what is the basic level of awareness just isn't
there at all.
Because historically it has been a luxury to eat sweets and everything.
So even if you look at the terminology and some Indian languages,
diabetes is the king's disease.
What sort of message?
Also,
right?
Like,
I mean,
here it's blueberries,
maybe it's mangoes or something that's an India that people really liked it.
That is what most,
yeah,
they're very sweet,
right?
But it tastes good.
It tastes good and they're healthy.
So,
so that,
that's the text message program as we really tell people what they should do
instead,
we don't give them any statistical data at all.
What we do is these changes would help you,
would help your family.
Um,
you know,
but that's the rub is that a lot of these things that are quite healthy have
become expensive.
And that's what we're always trying to balance.
And that's true with as well here among,
um,
you know,
lower income groups.
So that's always some,
the challenge of,
you know,
you can give people information that's not actionable.
So we're always trying to refine.
And so we have a very different messages in the workplace program,
for example,
versus what goes out to a more general population,
sort of how can you continue to eat like a popper
can afford?
That's difficult.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right,
well thank you Dr. Paul upon Dr Prahalad.
Thank you everyone for coming.